with Drake and Josh I felt pissed
that started this whole mess
he's an actor comedian one half of Drake
and Josh a staple of my childhood
the headline of the first 10 years of my
life was a single mom never knew my dad
didn't have enough money for a slice of
pizza 15 years old Drake and Josh one
would assume that you'd be like set for
life there was no residuals and I'm as
worried about next year's financial
status as anyone else I don't have that
security and I I do want to say that I
was not properly appreciated for my work
if I wanted to at will I could blow that
up 18 years old you lose 127 pounds yeah
one would assume that dropping 127
pounds would make you feel different
about yourself I dealt with the effect
but I didn't deal with the cause it was
anger at my dad it was anger at my
circumstance everything was going right
and I still didn't feel like enough
substituting what I used food for with
drinking and with other substance at 21
it all came barreling down on me I hurt
relationships and work I worried the
people that love me and I realized that
I needed to do something and what you do
in that moment government decides what's
going to happen next for you you cannot
think your way in the right acting you
have to act your way into right thinking
is there anything that's really helped
you that you might recommend to someone
listening at home yes so
before this episode starts I have a
small favor to ask from you two months
ago 74 of people that watch this channel
didn't subscribe we're now down to 69 my
goal is 50 so if you've ever liked any
of the videos we've posted if you like
this channel can you do me a quick favor
and hit the Subscribe button it helps
this channel more than you know and the
bigger the channel gets as you've seen
the bigger the guests get thank you and
enjoy this episode
[Music]
having read through your story
extensively it's quite clear to me that
the the most pertinent part of your
story and really like the through line
Begins the sort of dot in that through
line begins with this
Dynamic your parents had
when you were very very young can you
take me back to
1980s in New York to give me the context
that I'll need to understand to
understand the things we're going to
talk about today
sure I I was born in 1986. I uh was born
to a single mom and I never knew my dad
I was sort of the result of a
I guess what you would call a fling
um my mom always says you were a
surprise not an accident so I like the
way she the messaging she's attached to
that but basically my mom and dad knew
each other sort of through business
they had a night
and nine months later came me so sort of
so many different especially now having
two kids of my own knowing how
the process of creating life can be uh
tenuous and random and arbitrary and it
can be incredibly easy or incredibly
hard to know that they were together
once and
it just sort of happened that way is uh
kind of crazy makes you believe like oh
maybe I'm meant to be here at least
that's what I tell myself but yeah I uh
I was the result of that and my mom who
was 43 at the time knew that she'd
always wanted to have a child but wasn't
sure if she ever would
and immediately took it as sort of this
gift and my father who was in his 60s at
the time and had a whole other family
looked at it differently and decided not
to be in my life and I wound up never
meeting him and so
my Origins were very much my mom and I
sort of navigating the world together
I at an early age did you get a feel for
what your mom's your mother's
perspective was on your father did you
did you feel the emotion of that
how her perspective on him
my mom was weirdly unemotional about my
dad
I would say it was
almost like the fog of war or I remember
when I I interviewed Laird Hamilton and
I asked him the very corny cliche
question of when you're on a 90-foot
wave what's going through your head
and he's like you know your body will
sort of give you a bit of Amnesia so I
really can't tell you when you're in
extreme circumstance your body is a way
of like washing your memory and we see
that phenomenon too with like childbirth
right because if those hours during
childbirth really were as strong as as
they are when you are experiencing it
we'd all be only children right but the
brain has a wonderful way of washing
that away so my mom
did a really good job of presenting all
the good qualities of my dad that he was
a great business person that he was
Charming that he was handsome
I you know he was like the Jewish James
Bond walking the streets of New York
this handsome raccoon tour I I say in my
book you know he seemed pretty Sterling
his only sort of negative was that he
really didn't want anything to do with
me
so I think it wasn't until I got older
that my mom sort of elaborated a little
bit more with details
what was that what was the emotion
between you and your mother and the
emotion in the household at the time
growing up only money was tough and
things were slightly difficult
especially because your father had
chosen not to be part of your life but
what was the emotion in your household
you know below the age of 10.
the emotion in my household growing up
if I had to if I had to find a headline
right because sure if you zoomed in on
any moment I could have been
bullied at school or feeling insecure or
feeling less than than my friends who
had traditional family systems or how
come I don't get to experience that
surely there was plenty of that but if
we're talking about a headline of the
first 10 years of my life it was
a very extremely loving childhood
um not without its challenges and we
would sort of oscillate between moments
of of being extremely middle class and
then having not enough money for a slice
of pizza between us but inevitably even
through the struggles we were
there was a level of of comedic relief
you know we were always taking the piss
out of ourselves my mom's a natural
comedian her being a self-made
businesswoman especially in the 70s and
80s when she had to be
uh forced her to be extremely funny and
extremely Savvy and um
sort of puckish about the way in which
she navigated the world and men and
institutions and so I would say that
um most of the time we were laughing
and there were certainly times where we
were we were crying but but it was
mostly laughter when you um when you
talk about your mother is the words you
use will miss make it sound more like a
partnership than a mother-son
relationship it sounds like you were
like
you know partners
certainly we were Partners I mean a
single mom and an only child you are
immediately elevated to co-pilot whether
you like it or not I always say that
traditional families growing up were
more like I viewed them as close
corporations and that kids were
employees and the parents were upper
management and the upper management was
sort of beckoning down orders from the
top and maybe they were seniority
because there was an older sibling but
inevitably everyone sort of had the same
Pace structure and then for my mom and I
we were more like a startup right so one
day I was pitching the clients and she
was sweeping the floors and uh most days
it was the other way around so yeah I
was
I was the man in my mom's life
yeah
did you have any
um
you know when you start talking in your
book about
the pain that you were experiencing that
led you to to food and that you know
ultimately led to bullying and all of
those things what was that pain
well I think
I could make it I'm going to speak
generally
as a reflection of something specific
that went on with me but I I dare I
project that we're all in a certain
level of of pain
um
the veil of adolescence Falls for for
all of us at different times in our
lives where we realize that the world is
unfair or we become more attuned to
where we are not enough in certain areas
and the universe having a beautiful
level of balance it's it's inevitable
right I don't know of any of Tom Brady's
shortcomings but he's got to have one
he's probably hiding it from the world
but
um there's always something that that
for for us is is a challenge or
something that's uncomfortable and I
think you'd be hard-pressed to zoom in
on any kid and especially pre-teen and
teen who doesn't feel like Ultra
sensitive that the world is unfair
wrestling with their place in this world
their identity forming their identity so
for me I just feel like that was
impressed upon me at a really young age
if what's particular to me as I was
really young and uh
I think that was because of the dad
stuff I think that was because I was
overweight so I just knew that life was
going to be more challenging with the
set of circumstances that were at that
point felt like sort of thrust upon me I
didn't know that I was sort of eating in
a
in an unhealthy way I just felt like I
eat fruit snacks like every other kid I
just you know do it
um in an excessive way
so I think that pain was just born out
of
what we all feel is that it hurts to be
different and it hurts to know that life
is going to be challenging
you earlier when you said the word
comedic relief when you're talking about
the relationship with you and your
mother
comedic relief
the word relief almost makes it sound
medicinal like some kind of medicine in
your household what what role did comedy
play in your your early years
a comedy is
for my mom and I it's it's everything
it's everything we loved watching movies
and television together sitcoms and
stand-up comedy
it was a release it was a superpower it
was something that came to both of us
naturally I'm sure as as a byproduct of
my mom's rearing and upbringing and she
even talks about her her dad who I
didn't know my grandfather who sounds
like a pretty deeply imperfect guy but
was a showman and did love to tell jokes
and be funny and a bit of the center of
attention and so
for us it was uh it was a currency it
was something that worked immediately
and it could control the energy of a
room it could endear people to you so
you could really use it to your
advantage but if anything it was a
wonderful distraction
the other thing you describe as a
distraction is um is TV yes you refer to
it as an escape View at that time in
your life
um and you said in your book happy
people are annoying
um that sitcoms were your favorite why
were they your favorite
well sitcoms especially at that time I
talk about how my best friends growing
up were The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air and
Billy Madison and Happy Gilmore and
um
sitcoms had some Universal sort of
qualities in my experience it projected
a healthy family right so it was family
matters it was I guess Full House was
sort of it was a healthy sort of um
non-classic family right because it was
the dad and the uncles but these were
people that these were families that I I
wanted to be a part of
and then there was a Justice to the
comedy in the sense of you didn't have
to interpret it it wasn't objective or
I'm sorry it wasn't subjective it was
objective it was clear what worked and
what didn't it got a laugh and at that
time it was a live studio audience so
you know something Gotta Laugh
and uh
and I would just lose myself in hours of
watching these television shows
and I was absorbing The rhythms and the
qualities through osmosis I didn't even
know it at the time but it also served
as this wonderful escape and
I say that becoming an actor was like
for me going to work for the hospital
that cured my disease you know it felt
like my way of saying thank you for
taking care of me during that time what
was the disease
well I I that's a metaphor but yeah it's
just like sort of a metaphor for my
discomfort for
um having a lot of time on my hands
because I was an only child uh because
my mom had to work a lot to support us
because there was some Financial
insecurity just sort of all of the
discomfort going on in between my ears
um was sort of muted when I was losing
myself in those shows
one of the other things that we've
touched on briefly that you describe in
a
medicinal manner um I think the quote in
your book is actually I didn't know it
at the time but obviously I was
definitely medicating something deep
within
for me when I think about my childhood
the singular powerful and all-consuming
memory that comes to mind as being fat
it wasn't a habit it was a love my first
love
when you're talking about food oh yeah
well that's how you put on the weight
yeah food is great I mean you're a very
fit person but I imagine you're you're a
fan of food I love food everybody does
the whole world does you know it's not
like the biggest food guy who John
Stamos and I don't mean to drop names
here but we did a show together and he's
like you know I could eat a turkey
sandwich and be okay with it like most
days and it's like sometimes I'll forget
to eat and yeah I like a nice meal here
and there but I'm not too absorbed with
it and I'm like I don't identify with
this
you and I are built differently John
well we know we know John Stamos is
built different
um but yeah I mean the whole world's
obsessed with food I was obsessed with
it in a way that led to me being very
overweight
when you say very very of a weight how
much is that in I guess the metric here
is pounds isn't it I can give you kilos
no I can't but what's kilos about two
and a half
pounds 2.2
um you want to do stones I know you're
from the UK pounds
well 14 15 cents yeah I think well like
basically it's funny because I was just
kind of like a normal sized human until
around eight or nine and then I got kind
of chubby and then I put on a lot of
weight but it was only from about 13 to
18 uh where I was about uh 100 pounds
overweight I was about 290 pounds
okay which is 130 kilograms probably and
you're you're in nine or ten you said uh
no I I really put that weight on
probably around nine or ten I was
probably 180 190 but I was only you know
five foot and then as I got a little
bigger and older and also could you know
go to restaurants or grab fast food by
myself I I put on the pounds I've come
to learn over the the years actually
quite recently the um the role the link
between how I feel and how I eat yes you
know I mean there's lots of these links
in our lives you know one of them is how
we feel and money
um how we feel and how we eat
um I'm sure there's many many more but
um these are all like psychological
Tools in many respects and medicinal
tools often was there a point when you
realized that the link between
your relationship with food and how you
were feeling
yeah I mean it came later uh
understanding the nuance and the
correlation but I mean this is why
actors smoke right like traditionally
whenever you see movies where where it's
it's about show business and you see the
actor sort of hanging outside of a Sound
Stage because you do a take you do a
scene you're not sure how it went you
think you were good you hope you know
there was one take that was good but
maybe they're going to use the take kind
of sucked and you're full of emotion and
you're unsure and you're insecure
and there's a table of food waiting for
you right beautiful craft service like
you've never seen hot and cold and then
but instead you're like what can I do to
give me that sort of dopamine hit
without you know giving me the calories
so you know people go outside and smoke
obviously now smoking's not as uh in
fashion so you see less of it but I
remember once I was working with this
actor Paget Brewster she's just a gem
brilliant actor and she played my mom on
this TV show and I I'll never forget
once they were serving pizza as sort of
of like the late night meal
because we're working long hours and
and I remember her pulling the cheese
and like pepperoni off the top of the
pizza and eating it and she just sort of
said this is the actress pizza right
without the bread I was like how
perfectly set right and so yeah I think
we we all run to food because it's
represented to us as this it's a
celebratory thing it's also something
you do when things don't work out
it's a cheat day but like think about
those words right we reward ourselves
with cheating
um right it's a funny sort of corollary
but
um
and it's ubiquitous it's holiday it's
pumpkin spice season at uh at Starbucks
like all of these every great event is
accompanied by a meal even the worst
events right like what do you hope for
after a funeral well there'll be a nice
spread we'll go back and we'll have a
nice spread when you say you were you
were medicating something deep within
it seems like a relationship with food
was a little bit more
um
unique shall I say yeah so I think a lot
of I don't think a lot of people would
say that they
are using food as a way to medicate
something deep within
well they're probably using it it's in
some version of uh to medicate but maybe
not it I I did it in excess right I did
it to an extreme
in an extreme way yes there's a paradox
there which you highlight in your book
where you say that like you're doing it
to ease pain but it caused more pain
which is um I guess is the is the case
with a lot of things where we have a
unbalanced relationship with them where
like there's the short-term reward of
the dopamine hit that you describe but
then the long term punishment is like
the critique right and the self the
self-talk I guess and the the teasing is
you you refer to it in your book hmm
that's you you experience that that the
kind of like short-term pursuit of the
dopamine history short-term pain or um
short-term gain long-term pain yeah yeah
I mean it's a paradox of addiction right
it's it's us running to
I heard it said once someone in in
recovery said my disease lies in my dis
ease
I become uncomfortable and my coping
mechanism the thing that my brain is
trained to do is to go to these things
that numb the feeling uh it's another
great term numb and run you know uh it
numbs the feeling it cauterizes it
temporarily but inevitably it never
deals with the underlying issue so that
continues to grow and push the boulder
up so it requires more and more
medication and thus you know it makes
you more and more unhappy so you know
whether that's food or drug or drink or
smoking sex you know gambling debt
whatever your thing is it's I mean it's
it's just whatever's triggering I would
I would think that dopamine serotonin
sort of response
it's pretty crazy that at like eight
years old you were
already doing stand up yeah that's
that's boggles my mind at eight years
old I was doing nothing productive
I bet you were doing uh probably the
things eight-year-olds should do like
times tables and yeah geography and yeah
stuff like that like kicking a ball
against the wall yeah on my own or with
a friend
you were doing stand up at eight you
know I had a I had I had a couple of
comedians on this podcast and they all
there's this ongoing collect stereotype
that like a comedian is depressed or
something and one of the comedians said
to me that um a better question to ask I
think it was Jimmy Carr he said a better
question to ask is like which one of
your parents were you trying to make
happy ah Jimmy Carr is so fun he's funny
isn't he what a super like he's like a
Jedi he's on another level
sure what parent are you trying to make
happy
what girl are you trying to impress
I just think that we know that most
assets are born out of
feelings of being not enough you know uh
how many great athletes were were
created because they were trying to
impress their fathers right admonishing
fathers help make very ambitious young
men you know and and young women I don't
mean to gender it um
the problem is is the duality of that
because inevitably once hopefully you've
achieved that you realize that there's
no there there that there's no perfect
moment that's going to heal that
relationship with that parent or worse
you don't you don't attain those things
and then you're left to wonder well
what what could it have been and I fell
short I wasn't enough but
comedy is one of those more specific
things because there is there's a
Justice to it
um it's there's not a lot up for
interpretation it's clear
uh it's more like boxing I think Chris
rocket can akin to boxing which is why
they call it a punch line and you know
it's on the cards that punch connected
that one didn't you get a point for that
you don't get a point for this
and
yeah I think it's just born out of you
know being funny usually comes from very
unfunny reasons and you know growing up
and I I don't mean to say this even now
like when I'll I'll meet someone who's
like really uh I'll just name names it's
like and he is funny but it's like
sometimes when I watch Like Ashton
Kutcher go like in a really hard comedy
and he's done some really really funny
things I know this is what you're gonna
clip me like trashing I I want to be
Ashton Kutcher I look up to him I love
you Ashton I'm available for friendship
and I love your wife I love them both
but it's like it's sometimes it's hard
for me to reconcile how someone can be
that gorgeous and handsome and um and
also funny right like sometimes I do
feel like no Funny's got to be reserved
for us you know who who who weren't
necessarily that because yeah it was
used as a defense mechanism
did you know you wanted to be a comedian
or an actor and if so when did you when
did that idea become cemented in your
brain that that's the path you were
going to pursue
being an actor professionally didn't
seem like a reasonable career path
sometimes it still doesn't but here I am
um it was ridiculous I grew up in New
York I'm not a nepo baby I have no
connection to show business other than a
very sticky mother do you know this word
schtick yeah okay you're like I have a
mom who loves a bit and she's a natural
performer it's a beautiful singing voice
but no literally no connections to show
business in any way so it was not
reasonable to think that there would be
any opportunity to do it professionally
and then I was in sixth grade and my mom
and I were having a really tough moment
financially
we're living in an apartment on the east
side of Manhattan it was like a studio
apartment and we would sort of switch
off between the bed and the couch one
night I'd get to bed one night I get the
couch and
and I remember my mom saying you know
there's a performing arts high school
that you should audition for
and I said but I'm gonna go to the high
school in my district like where my
elementary school was
she goes you don't have a district
anymore
we don't live there anymore
and I realized okay well yeah maybe I'll
give this the school a shot because I'm
not going to be in high school now with
my friends who I grew up with
and I auditioned and I went and I got in
and suddenly I'm walking the halls of
this school the professional performing
arts school which is in the Theater
District in New York near Times Square
and
they had alumni like Alicia Keys and
Jesse Eisenberg and Claire Danes
and they were all older than me but all
of a sudden I'm seeing kids who are in
Broadway shows TV shows and they're
studying but they're also successful on
this like grown-up level and it seemed
possible that you could make a living
doing this thing that I loved
so I remember that was the first time
where I had a suspicion like oh this
this might be a long-term gig and
eventually then once I basically once it
became a way out of my circumstance and
it allowed me to sort of contribute to
the family financially I was I was all
in it just seemed like an escape
and you were what age then like 12 16 I
think I was 12 yeah
and then by 16 a chance meeting with
someone from Nickelodeon sends things in
another Direction no that was 12. oh
when you were 12. I used to audition
like every other day
um and Nickelodeon their their Viacom
headquarters was in Times Square I've
been yeah yeah another one yeah and
I auditioned for a movie I got it
they fly me to Canada never been out of
the country now
if you're going to go out of the country
for the first time making Canada because
it's lovely and I'm sitting there one
day in in Calgary Canada
making jokes to some 40 year old guy
with a great laugh and a huge Park up
and my mom Saddles up to me and she goes
you know who that is so you're making
laugh that's
that's the president of Nickelodeon a
guy named Albie hacked you should tell
him that you want to be on all that
which was kind of SNL for kids at that
time it was my dream
so I told them and nine months later he
called and said Josh I'm gonna move you
and your mom out to California to go be
on The Amanda Show which was the
spin-off for Amanda Bynes from all that
and that was
kind of what changed my life and brought
me out to LA and gave me my first TV
show and kind of started this whole mess
this whole mess
ing way to describe it it boggles my
mind that you're doing that at 12. I I
am
I I don't even know how that's possible
for you know it feels like there's a lot
of other things we're meant to be doing
when we're 12. you were you were working
essentially yeah yeah it was
what did you miss did you miss anything
I'm in hindsight a lot I mean you can
speak to a better I don't know what I
didn't miss I mean but you if you had a
more traditional sort of adolescence
right
did you yeah I did yeah yeah yeah so
like school stuff like the prom and
playing football and with the team and
you know Primary School primary school
as well yeah figuring yourself out more
than anything uniforms I wish I went to
school in the UK it seems awesome
yeah it's not bad yeah yeah I loved
Matilda room for improvement um it's
dope it's uh it's such a classic I am
um yeah I I missed out on a lot
absolutely
um
you know it's funny people love this
question it kills me I don't know why
because now I have two sons of my own
and they're always like you got to put
them in Show Business like it's weird I
I don't know why that is I don't know if
people say to lawyers or Carpenters like
is your son gonna hit nails like are you
gonna like read your son depositions
I guess because the idea is that why
wouldn't you want them to and while I
would love for them to if they love
performing to to find some joy in it
my upbringing my circumstance was so
specific
it was inevitable that if this was meant
for me that it was going to be meant for
me and I mean that as
we could move 3 000 Miles because it was
just me and my mom you know we could
uproot our whole life
I I was an overweight kid so I didn't
get a lot of self-esteem from the
traditional systems that people the kids
gain it from but I found this performing
thing so of course my mom goes well I'm
going to nurture this
the way I would if it were little league
or it was an instrument
so my environment my upbringing allowed
for me to go on this really
non-traditional path my kids don't have
that they have a very different
experience they have like a very rooted
household they have a huge family they
have a mom and dad and it's not
necessarily that one's better than the
other but it's just like
their experience will be different and
if when my son's 18 and he's like I want
to go to Juilliard or I want to do it
professionally that's great but maybe
his circumstance won't lend itself to
start that early
it's so interesting yeah but it makes so
much sense you know
that circumstance and struggle are
factors that orientate us towards
um
towards our mission and it's so you know
I I think we often understate how like
trauma and things we'd never wish on a
child end up creating their Brilliance
you think about like the the
Brilliance you've created the work
you've created that is brilliant so much
of it has a through line way back to
things that you would never wish on your
kids yes right
15 years old you start um filming the
pilot for Drake and Josh
one of the things I found really
interesting when I was reading through
your book is one would assume that
such a hit show a show that we all knew
very very well in the UK
off the back of it one would assume that
you'd be like set for life financially
yeah and you write about how that's like
that's that's that was certainly not the
case
yes and I I do want to say that
my first Kids Choice Award was one
at the UK Kids Choice Awards in London
now I had been nominated a lot a lot I
had said sour grapes but allow me to
continue I was not
properly appreciated for my work
in the American Kids Choice Awards but
it took you brilliant
people in the United Kingdom to
appreciate my my my overweight but
wonderfully comedic work as a young
actor so I want to thank you
um
yeah I
I think look I'm so pleased to talk
about this stuff with you someone who's
like has wonderful insight into the book
and and is interested and it felt like
the book for me was sort of like
I don't I I really I don't do a lot of
this anymore and because the book felt
like sort of a chapter ending in my life
it was me editorializing my life it was
commenting on the things that I felt
were perhaps misunderstood or didn't
have enough clarification or description
and also in an effort unknowingly to
sort of say like and now I'm not I'm
going to talk about it less and if
someone is interested like they can you
know read the book and it's it's now you
know in the the Library of Congress but
and so to that point I felt the need
because over the years people would
either say it in a cheeky way like oh
well you don't have to worry because of
the residuals or they would see just
something random like you know it would
actually
be part of decision making or something
that it would apply to me they're like
well Josh doesn't have to worry and I
was like well I'm not complaining but
I'm I'm as much you know worried about
next year's financial status as anyone
else because I don't have that security
so yeah with Drake and Josh there was no
residuals and kids CV didn't have that
at that time and
I got really honest and I sort of broke
it down because Ryan holiday my friend
and sort of advisor on the book was like
if you don't it's he's like it's gross
to talk about money but if you don't
actually give a a sort of exact picture
of what it was then people won't
understand and so I sort of talk about
that
you know while doing the show we made
about a hundred thousand dollars a year
for the four years we were making it
which is great money in a lovely middle
class lifestyle but no one would assume
that once you stop working that you
never had to work again so I just wanted
to give some clarity to that to sort of
explain the choices that I made after
and why I was so passionate about
finding more work because I um I had
some people to take care of
makes perfect sense and I think it's
really important context because
um you're right it's very easy when you
don't know entertainment contracts
especially for for a young person that's
15 odd years old to assume that they
made millions and millions in perpetuity
from that piece of work and then a lot
of the the decisions and the choices
they're after don't have are lacking in
context yeah when I read that it was
like I understood of course if you make
a hundred thousand dollars in the United
States living in California whatever it
is for five years in a row you do need
to go back to work and yeah after Drake
and Josh ended was there was there like
a pivotal moment where you realized that
that show was big
um it wasn't until much later funny
enough I am
I think because when we were making it
it was only popular with kids who were
sort of younger who I didn't other than
if I was at a mall or at a theme park I
didn't have a huge amount of uh
interaction with and then I would say
that the the power of the show
to its credit was that it was slightly
Timeless because it had a very sort of
classic through line of any sitcom it
was about a family
and a lot of kids shows can be more
Fantastical and have more of a Sci-Fi
bent or something more fantasy or
whimsical this was just like very
straight down the line two brothers who
are very different trying to get along
uh and an evil little sister so because
of how much it was rerun
more Generations would come to the show
and these people grew up so it wasn't as
though it was this moment in time it was
every year we were picking up new fans
because there was what 60 episodes or
something yeah just like there was so
much more I know it's weird why is that
I guess reruns yeah it played for so
long over the last couple of how long
maybe four months I've been changing my
diet shall I say many of you have really
been paying attention to this podcast
will know why I've sat here with some
incredible Health experts and one of the
things that's really come through for me
which has caused a big change in my life
is the need for us to have these
superfoods these green Foods these
vegetables and then a company I love so
much and a company I'm an investor in
and then a company that sponsors this
podcast and I'm on the board of recently
announced a new product which absolutely
spoke to exactly where I was in my life
and that is huel and they announced
Daily Greens Daily Greens is a product
that contains 91 superfoods nutrients
and plant-based ingredients which helps
me meet that dietary requirement with
the convenience that hewell always
offers unfortunately it's only currently
available in the US but I hope
pray that it'll be with you guys in the
UK too so if you're in the US check it
out it's an incredible product I've been
having it here in La for the last couple
of weeks and it's a game changer ladies
and gentlemen our newest brand
partnership will come is no surprise to
regular listeners on this podcast the
first episode of 2023 I was joined by
the incredible Professor Tim Spector to
hear more about his work at a company
called Zoe using data to understand our
bodies better so that we can live more
fulfilled higher potential lives Zoe was
born from the truth that our overall
health is impacted by our gut health by
helping you to understand how your body
is working so he can help you to reduce
your risk of long-term disease and
increase your energy levels for me this
is the future and that is why I became
an investor in the company and that is
why they are now a sponsor of this
podcast you can read up about everything
they're doing and you can pre-order your
Zoe program at join zoe.com and they've
been kind enough to offer an exclusive
10 off code CEO 10. so you can put that
code in at checkout CEO 10.
after Drake and Josh ended and as you go
into you're like you you know the next
chapter of your life 18 years old you
lose a lot of weight I do
a lot of weight
127 pounds yeah
how how does that's not an easy feat
how does that happen
I certainly made a decision that I was
ready to do it
um I think I just I always knew that I
was going to do it and also in writing
the book it's
when you put pen to paper
and I know you're a writer yourself it's
amazing how these I feel as though we
make these um everything in our brain is
sort of shorthand right it's like these
picture memories that are connected uh
and sometimes they're connected by these
really strong connections and sometimes
it's just like short little hits but
when you're forced to actually explain
it on a page it makes you look at it
differently and I was like wow I was
only heavy from like
13 to 17. of course they're the years
that have been enshrined in television
history forever so it feels much bigger
but had I just been like a normal kid I
would have burned my yearbooks and sworn
my family to secrecy and I'd never bring
it up so
I think it was a number of things I was
ready I think naturally like my body was
ready to let go of it and I just knew
that I
I felt like because I was so insecure
I had missed out on a lot of my teenage
years
um it wasn't without lack of opportunity
to go out and and be a knucklehead and
experience life I just didn't want to do
it because I didn't love the body that I
was in so I felt like if I didn't if I
didn't act now I was going to lose some
really important years
is there is there a process that helped
because I'm thinking about how you
referred to it as being like medicinal
your relationship with food and that's
like deeply psychological so to like
append that deep psychological force or
that relationship with food there's no
easy feat so like what what's the
process is it therapy is it what that
that makes your that kind of appends
that psychological force or replaces it
or
I think it was I I had been I've I've
had a therapist that that I've gone to
since I was 15 and and I still see here
and there so my mom kind of knew I think
she saw it in me early on that there was
just a lot going on be it my dad or the
weight stuff and then I think I would
just
in the way that that change is born you
know pain is a great motivator I was
sort of sick and tired of being sick and
tired and I I knew that I had to let go
of something I don't think I knew
exactly what it was but if I'm looking
back at it now it was like it was this
anger it was anger at my my dad it was
anger at my circumstance and
I just remember I was 17 years old my
mom and I would drive back to New York
every year for like two months and we
would just go and see family and hang
out in the city
and I just started to walk
and up until then I would do these
really intense you know attempts at keto
or
these extreme diets on a Monday and I
would fail by Wednesday morning and then
it would be back on again but this time
I said I'm just going to try to make a
small change every day
and I would walk the city for miles and
I would listen uh to music and I would
dream of what my life could be
and I started eating better and slowly
but surely that summer I lost like 40
pounds and then over the next year I
lost another 40 and then over the next
year I lost another 40. in chapter five
of your book you say you had a new body
but the exact same self-hating mind
one would assume that you know dropping
127 pounds one would naively assume that
dropping 127 pounds would
would make you feel different about
yourself yeah
well it's um
to sort of the themes that you've
mentioned throughout this interview it's
it's cause and effect right like I dealt
with the effect but I didn't deal with
the cause and unfortunately there were
some issues at play there were some
um unresolved pain and work that needed
to be done that I wasn't even aware of
but it was all at play Under the surface
so when I no longer had that thing that
was helping to sort of keep those
feelings at Bay they reared their head
and I needed to find something else I
didn't know that it was going to be in
the form of uh you know drinking and and
sort of uh alcohol's cousins but I uh
I just knew that when I finally did find
those things and I did sigh that bit of
relief that I'd been looking for I I
think there was even a moment in that
first night when I went out with some
other kids my age and really tied one
off and thought I was having like a
proper teenage time I remember this this
voice in my head being like oh this is
it like this is what we've been looking
for
um drinking
yeah the drinking and drugs and I I I I
think I see something in the book of
like if you've been carrying this
invisible bag of stones around your
whole life a weight vest with 50 to 100
extra pounds I mean I quite literally
was but let's just say it's like
emotional weight vest and
eventually you almost forget that it's
on you just know your knees hurt
you know you're exhausted it's like why
am I so tired why did why does why do
things feel tougher for me than it does
for my friends
and then if in an instant that weight
vest is lifted off of you and your knees
hurt less and you're walking around and
you're like oh
you wouldn't question it you just be
like whatever just took that weight vest
off I'm in and that's that was the
reaction that I had
such an interesting analogy
the the weight vest you know you said
the term self-hating mind
for someone that hasn't experienced a
self-hating mind what is what is that
like in detailed reality
is it literally thoughts that you can
recall that are saying
being pessimistic hmm
I I probably if I could um
edit my book now I would be probably
less um
I'd be less revealing no I would
I would be less
um I would be a little harder on myself
and say I
it's self-centered if we're talking
about the root of it I remember when I
got in when I got sober people would say
you're self-centered and I would say
self-centered that's reserved for people
who think highly of themselves that's
reserved for the quarterbacks the models
the good looking the self-absorbed
people to me felt
when you would see that in movies it was
someone who was staring in the mirror
and perfecting their hair and they would
say no if you spend all your time
thinking about how great you are or how
[__] you are all you're thinking about
is you and you are self-centered it
doesn't matter whether it's great or bad
so
I wouldn't yeah I would substitute
self-hating with self-centered I was
obsessed with self
my trauma was real my challenges were
real and that played a part in it but I
was just so wrapped up in
my feelings of feeling less than an
uncomfortable and not proverbially not
at the cool table that
um
I you know found myself in a place to
numb my my feelings because those
thoughts were were unrelenting
Nothing in life nothing in life is free
and so even a temporary lifting of the
weight vest comes with a long-term cost
as we talked about with food what was
that that long-term cost of temporarily
getting to lift the weight vest once in
a while
I just became a cliche quick I I heard
relationships and work I worried the
people that loved me I I just started to
accrue a lot of wreckage quickly it's
it's funny I interviewed Hillary Duff on
my podcast
um Good Guys the other day and we made a
joke I was asking her about like
um
we were she brought up something about
like oh I love an alcoholic beverage and
she kind of looked at me and said sorry
Josh and I was like no I love an
alcoholic beverage too unfortunately
whenever I drink it leads to my other
favorite beverage Percocet
which is a very popular painkiller in
this country
um
and I remember people sort of
saying like they were so sort of they
just didn't know sort of my
um they they didn't know that part of my
history right so it was something that I
it was this thing that I was sort of
navigating and balancing kind of how
much I would sort of
talk about it and and uh and reveal and
then also sort of this this balancing of
like the things that I also wanted to
keep private
when did you realize that that you had a
a problem with alcohol or an unhealthy
relationship with alcohol and drugs was
there a because at the time I imagine
you don't
the first time you do it you don't know
it's not a problem then is it but at
some point you must have maybe got some
feedback or something indicated that
this was not
oh and I'm sorry I forgot the point I
was trying to make with the Hillary
thing but oh someone wrote a comment on
that clip and that video said damn Josh
Peck got sober at 21 he really went for
it so to answer your follow-up question
yeah I mean I think that
I basically was
substituting what I used food for
with these you know with with drinking
and with other substance but it was all
sort of connected so it wasn't this
four-year run it was really like since I
was 9 or 10 years old it just was again
validating and reconfirming this idea of
like you overdo things
and nothing is going to fill up this
hole in the soul no matter what you try
to fill it with and even like the things
that our
um
World tells us is a value even success
isn't going to do it even if girls like
you it's not enough and so I remember at
21 having a moment like that when it all
sort of came
sort of barreling down on me and I
realized that I needed to do something
now I think people have those moments
and they don't do anything and they lose
another four years or five or ten or
Twenty
um but I do think the world and life
catastrophe challenging circumstance
some version of a bottom whatever you're
going through being fired from something
a health scare has a way of temporarily
waking you up and what you do in that
moment
um
decides what what's going to happen next
for you
you said that happened for you at 21
years old was that was that in the wake
of the film The whackness it was yeah
that was certainly a moment tell me
about that moment well again I I had
accrued plenty of wreckage but I
remember I
I had done this movie The whackness that
I was extremely proud of with my
favorite actor sir Ben Kingsley you know
and I mean literally my favorite actor
like getting a you know have my rookie
season with Michael Jordan and
and it went to the Sundance Film
Festival and I was so proud and we got a
standing ovation and it just felt like
such a confirmation for me as an actor
that there was going to be that that
there was going to be opportunity and
there was
there was more to come for my career
that it wasn't just this sort of anomaly
that I did this one show and that that
was sort of gonna be it
but I remember in that moment
all those similar feelings
that mind that had gotten me in trouble
so many times before was still yelling
at me and all those feelings were
flooding in they weren't there the night
we got they weren't there during the 90
seconds of the Sandy Innovation they
weren't there
you know when I was smiling in front of
the camera but they were there when I
got home they were there when I got in
bed they were there when I was waiting
in line for a coffee the next morning or
whatever else I was doing so it was like
so short-lived
and it just confirmed this idea of like
oh like even at your best even when
everything's kind of going right because
it's easy to use when when life throws
you challenges there's a reason to sort
of
you know co-sign your bad behavior
but everything was going right and I
still didn't feel like enough and I knew
at that point that I needed to make a
change or or
I might never do it
that next day off to the standing
ovation at the Sundance Film Festival
you talk about you know how you might
have felt standing in the coffee line or
the next day when you woke up Etc is
this are they are these specific
thoughts or is it just an emotional
state
is it just like a lowness
it's totally emotional and it's
ugly like the way like how we're all
pitiful in those moments I I don't think
you have to be
um suffer from addiction or it's just
like when we realize that our way isn't
working anymore and a change needs to
occur and
so yeah I I certainly it's taken 15 16
years to
articulated correctly I think it was
just the feeling you you your solution
to that feeling appears to be you know
when when you hit that proverbial Rock
Bottom moment
um to be getting some help and that's
where you turn to AAA Alcoholics
Anonymous hmm
what what is that Pro like what is what
is Alcoholics Anonymous and like how how
did it help you
turn things around and get sober
well you know it's sort of in the name
Anonymous that there's there's an
anonymity portion to it so I I I always
want to make sure it said that I'm in no
way sort of a representative or
Ambassador for it in any way it's just
how I have found a way in which to get
and stay sober over the last 15 years is
through through uh 12-step program and
it's just a way it's it's ancient truths
um repackaged to make sense to a guy
like me it's the best way it helps to
mitigate the worst of my Character
defects and it's just age-old
um it's just a sort of for me
an age-old way of of cleaning up your
past and and looking at bad patterns and
habits in my life and making amends and
trying to implement things that through
history we have known to work gratitude
surrender acceptance
if you want self-esteem do a steamable
acts restrain a pen and tongue you know
just like
um
you know it's not you know your higher
power is up to you as long as you know
that you're not God that one's a that
one's helpful it just presented some
ways in which for me to to apply things
to my life that helped me to to get and
stay sober so I think if if the efficacy
wasn't there if I didn't see quickly
that I started to feel better then maybe
I would have sought a different way this
this was a way that happened to work for
me
and you've been sober for some what 13
13 years 15 15. recently yeah just uh
February 15th congratulations thanks it
works for me yeah it's an incredible
incredible
um achievement you know everyone's got
their own relationship with with alcohol
and whatever else but it's always
incredible to hear
um someone being able to
turn a corner in the direction they
wanted to turn it it's the best way I
can describe it thank you 2013.
you kind of start from reading your book
it sounds like you start on a new a New
Journey and that's the journey to
understand who your father is you're 27
at this point so almost 30 years old and
your father passes away
um and you make the decision at that
point having not met him before and
having not seen a picture of him until
you were 24 years old to figure out who
he was hmm what did you learn about him
and how did that change your perspective
of him
well I remember I'd always sort of toyed
with this idea of meeting him and yet I
think I knew deep down I never would
because
my creation of him
in my head the way that I sold him to my
friends or or the way I would portray
him to people felt like my weird Cosmic
consolation prize like I don't get to
have him in any way but I can present
him to people in the way in which I
choose not that I was telling people
that my dad was you know the first man
on the moon or anything like that it
just was like you know my mom knew that
he was
that he was Jewish and that he was
Sephardic which is
um a type of Jew that tends to be from
either the Middle East or from Morocco
or or French or or can be South America
Mexican and and so for me I would just
like Ping Pong where he was from you
know sometimes he was from Spain
sometimes he was from Israel sometimes
he was from like I just would kind of
present it as I so fit and and it felt
like if I ever met him well then I I
lost Stephen the illusion or this
creation of my dad that I wanted to make
so I but when I found out that he passed
away it also felt like a little bit of
this thing that I've been carrying
around this emotional grenade that I
could you know I had the power in the
sense that I could show up and he had
this whole other family and these grown
kids and a wife and if I wanted to at
will I could blow that up for him if in
theory he never had told them anything I
was never going to do it but it was nice
to know right like whatever version my
head was telling me like to keep me warm
at night so when he passed away I was
like oh damn he won right perfect record
like he set his mind to something and he
stuck to it he's like I'm never gonna
meet that kid and he did it and I never
got that moment to sort of say like how
dare you I don't know if it would have
been that probably wouldn't have been it
probably would have been like hey I'm
your kid what's up like do you want to
get a coffee
um
but you know all of that was sort of
taken away from me so I felt
I felt pissed that I had to mourn this
guy that I never knew
and
that I was mourning like morning is
in theory sort of the worst part of it's
sort of the other side of love right
it's that the gift is you get to love
and the Embrace of someone and then what
comes with that is that eventually if
they're not here anymore you have to
mourn them you have to mourn what was I
was like there was nothing like and I
still have to get the crappy side of
this doesn't seem fair
but it forced me to do something that
inevitably led to my men's and my amends
that I gave myself which was I randomly
looked up uh his kids on Facebook
my friend figured out a way to my friend
a buddy of mine basically
was looking with me and was like oh I
there was a connection between him and
my sister they had attended a similar
like Workshop or some kind of like
education program he's like maybe under
the guise of that I could become her
friend and like then you know I could
see if on her profile she has any photos
to your dad I had never seen what he
looked like
she accepts it and I am immediately
given this like Treasure Trove of photos
of his life
and I'm seeing him at their bar mitzvahs
and and weddings and all these events
and I'm seeing these beautiful tributes
said his friends and family are making
to him after he passed away
and it made me realize that like what my
dad was for me wasn't the only part of
him
you know it certainly was a real part of
him but he also was this great dad just
not to me
and that's not
uh valid there are that's not not valid
that's um
that's a part of this imperfect man so
it like gave me a little bit of
forgiveness for this guy
and it made me realize that he was
probably scared and he had probably had
this great perfect record with his
family and then this blemish occurred
and he did the best that he could so in
a weird way seeing that he was good to
them
made me a little more okay that maybe he
wasn't great to me and and then of
course having the son of my own and
being the dad to my two boys now uh that
I wish my dad was for me was sort of
like the ultimate amends to
eight-year-old Josh
what's that Journey been like you know
from I almost view it as like a
an emotional Journey on like some kind
of like graph or something almost like a
roller coaster from when you were young
to where you are now in terms of the
perspective of your father and the
relationship you know was there was
there resentment at one point you seemed
to have gotten to a better place with it
now yeah but what's that Journey like
the resentment I think at its at its
highest is uh showcased in me being 100
pounds overweight right or you know my
struggles after that I I think that was
certainly
um it was all that resentment and anger
and frustration and unexplored feelings
presenting itself
as as whatever that was as those
addictions right they were in the
manifestation of a deeper issue they
were a symptom of a deeper issue I was
just pondering because I've I know
people that haven't had a relationship
with their father obviously nothing is
definitively causal like it doesn't
necessarily mean you can attack any
other way but um one of the the trends
you tend to hear about is when is that
connection between not believing you're
enough and your father not being around
are they connected for you like the the
do you know what I mean I'm saying does
the absence of your father did that ever
leave a thought that said he left but
you know that means I'm not enough
because he chose not to be here
it must right I I don't see how it
couldn't be right but what we what I've
also learned in Being Sober this song
and hearing a lot of other people's
experiences it my
um my story my feelings are not rare
but they're not a monolith they're not
singular yeah I've heard plenty of
stories of people who had like pretty
idyllic uprightings and they just happen
to suffer from this thing where they do
too much and this particular mental bend
that makes them look at life or makes
them seek out a way of numbing their
feelings so what I know now is that
certainly I think you're right it it was
part of my story but it's it's not the
only way I I think I've kind of grown in
that Trend in my mind has grown a little
bit because I spoke to gabo mate who's
there's a lot of childhood trauma stuff
and one of the things he said is that as
children we're narcissists I've never
been able to forget that and we think
everything is about us so right if you
know if the father leaves for example
instead of thinking well that's because
he has another family or because he's
scared or whatever it's that's about me
when you when you're younger
um and then you as you say you had your
own boy yes
now two boys crazy
two boys you have kids not yet I could
tell because you're in such good shape
were you scared to become a father
because of your own terrified
because I I just didn't I didn't have
any work-life experience yeah
um I just didn't know look I'm I'm a
mute I'm a I'm a formerly chubby musical
theater kid from New York like I don't I
never thought anything that was
masculine I never thought I had the
prerequisites for that that was like
inherently dudeish like I've always been
like a guy like I love boxing like I've
always broke down I've always you know
had all those inherent qualities but
those things that felt felt like
presentationally Macho or dude-esque I
was just like oh I don't I don't have
that and uh and so yeah I wanted to have
a girl and then when my son was born my
wife and I didn't find out the sex and
so you know at nine months and nine
months and a couple days when the doctor
was like what is it Josh and I got to
announce to the room like it's a boy
I was like oh of course because it was
required for me you know my life turned
into
man school you know especially in
sobriety
I had to learn and and I don't mean to
make it this blanket a definition I for
me what it meant to be a man and the
qualities that I had had to sort of
accrue the things that no matter how
great my mom was couldn't give me
because she was just limited by what one
person can do the things that I learned
from my big brother Dan I've had a big
brother in in the states we have the big
brother Foundation
I've had a big brother since I was eight
years old and things that I learned from
him and then eventually my father-in-law
who I really look up to and all the
great men in my life and all these these
assets these tools that I had learned
you know when I had my son Max I was
like okay here's my opportunity now to
implement that and see everything that
I've collected what I can give him and
uh it just felt perfect it felt like
God's way of like having a laugh and be
like you you knew this was going to
happen right
you married Paige yes you had they teach
your wonderful children
um
I had a guest on the podcast quite
recently who said who described somewhat
of a similar upbringing where the father
wasn't around and him and his mum acted
almost like pilot and co-pilot and he
one of the terms he said to me I can't
remember it was something something
ancestral or something I know that
sounds strange but it was something to
do with the fact that when you have such
a close relationship to your partner to
your mother and they end up
indirectly or unadvertently offloading
some of the emotional energy around the
parent that's not there it can make your
own personal relationships difficult
yeah can you relate
I can accept that I think that everyone
is bad at relationships and I think just
like I believe that even if you have a
perfect parental structure we will
self-parent there's always going to be
gaps in our rearing there's always going
to be
spots that were missed as a result of
your upbringing and your circumstance in
the way in which you've experienced life
up to a certain point and it's incumbent
on you to fill in those gaps that's
growing up right to even know what those
gaps are yes right what for you what
were those gaps you had to fill in well
I think it was with the dad stuff it was
about in relationships up into my wife
I had this like I would call it like the
Tony Montana approach to life which was
like if anything went wrong if there was
any sort of adversity or any kind of I
mean at this point right like I'm I've
dealt with the dad stuff and then I've
been in Showbiz till you know since I
was 10 right which is the ultimate
rejection right you're you're being
you're going on a job interview at best
even if you're on a TV show
you're interviewing for a job
once or twice a year and if you are an
out of work actor you're you're
interviewing for a job four times five
times a month sometimes more during
pilot season right so you really have to
calcify or uh calcified yeah like you
have to become uh callous to rejection
it's like if you ever talk to a doctor
like about death they have a very
interesting bet on it because they can't
be overly emotional about it because
it's a part of their job
so
until this point in relationships if
anything went South I just would go this
is a preview of more bad to come this
isn't natural Growing Pains this isn't
natural
um discourse or or just like the natural
arguments that you get in and then you
get through them and you become closer I
would just go this was great I'll be
fine without you thanks and I would just
go leaving people in my wake to be like
what the hell happened how did you
reverse that's the point that you were
able to find someone and get married
luckily
I was in a state of doing the work I was
willing to be I was not doing that
specific work but in general because I
was in a recovery program because my mom
had put good people around me and
because I had done therapy since I was a
kid I like knew I was self-aware enough
to know like oh there's there's
certainly work to be done here but it
wasn't until I had a woman like my wife
in my my life who taught me a better way
who came from a family that doesn't
leave and she reiterated that so when we
get in these fights and I would look at
her and be like so I guess we should
call it
like this was great right she'd be like
what like no like
I'm not going anywhere and neither you
and we can be mad at each other we can
be mad we can go to bed mad I love that
and people go you don't go to bed man
I'm like I don't know not in my
experience like you can go to bed you're
gonna be mad for a couple days usually
it doesn't last that long no one wants
to be that pissed that long but it's
like but when we work this out I'll be
here because I'm not going anywhere
because my siblings never went anywhere
my mom and dad never went anywhere like
we stick around through the good and the
bad and that was a revelation for me
I can so relate in so many ways I have
the same avoidant attachment stuff for
various reasons and then I met a person
I always say that like God over the wall
you know like yeah you know and changed
you from the inside
um definitely so I can totally totally
relate that's why you have to have a
that's why if if it's for you you have
to have a kid because in my experience
and I say it in the book you don't we
all work on ourselves and especially
with
incredible podcasts like this and we're
in the age of optimization and
self-realization and everyone's
listening to a dozen podcasts at a time
and wants to be their best version of
themselves and that's great but we can't
be Faberge eggs right like we can't be
these perfect pristine things and then
we get jostled around a bit by life and
we shatter and so to me I think there's
only so much work you can do on your own
and then it has to be like applied into
life and then you put some skin in the
game and you get in a relationship and
that forces you to go deeper and you're
like I don't want to and they're like
well you better otherwise this thing's
not gonna work but you meet someone of
value and you do the work and it reveals
itself to be worth it and it gives you a
deeper understanding and then once you
guys get really perfect you throw a kid
in the mix and that little jerk makes
you go even deeper and work even harder
and become even more selfless hopefully
and less self-centered and again new
truths are revealed in new ways of
living are revealed so yeah on all the
things we've talked about today the the
mental talk the voice in your head the
feelings of
um you know quote-unquote self-hatred
self-esteem happiness where where are
you as you sit here today on that
Journey
I I'm I'm in a wonderful place my life
you know is a reflection of
how do I say it my life is is that of a
good man's
now I I say that not in like some big
self-congratulatory way but I just did
the things that I was told to do by
people whose life I wanted
you know I surrounded myself with the
people who weren't telling me the things
I wanted to hear but their life looked
attractive and it wasn't because they
had a nice car or they had an impressive
job those things don't hurt but it was
because they seemed deeply decent that
they had a good spiritual life and that
they were good partners there were good
Fathers there were good sons and that
was attractive to me so I implemented
that into my life on a regular basis and
the byproduct of that was a really good
life that I'm completely overpaid to
have today
um and I still just as much as I say I
rarely wake up in the morning in the
mood for a salad
I usually want french toast I wake up in
the morning most times it's usually not
the morning I am a morning person it's
usually at four eight four a.m at night
or 2 A.M or five in the afternoon when
I'm over tired and I had too much sugar
when my mind starts going just remember
it's all going to be bad you know that
right
but I have tools you know I have ways in
which of dealing with that
to get out of those thoughts to break
that bad cycle
um so it's just the voices are never
gone but the volumes turn down
I have to ask you've got one last
question here in the diary that the last
guest has left for you but when you said
you have tools I was compelled because I
know that there's someone at home who
can completely relate and they're sat
there thinking Josh what are the tools
is there anything that's really helped
you sort of turn down the volume on that
that you might recommend to someone
listening at home
I would just say and um my friend John
AKA Wheels
um
his motto was action is the magic word
and you cannot think your way in the
right acting you have to act your way
into right thinking
and I always felt like
I'm reasonably articulate and I've you
know I've prided myself on having what I
thought was like a good mind I gotta be
able to think my way out of this thing
like I have to be able to impress my
will on this thing and wrestle it to
death like I I just can't believe it and
it's the duality of these things because
didn't I get myself this far
didn't mean taking my life and my will
into my hands didn't I get all this
success and notoriety and blah blah blah
and it's like well there was a part of
it that that but maybe you got that in
spite of it you know maybe the truth is
is that these things you know it they
need to be governed they need to be
throttled because inevitably
they'll pervert they will they'll ruin
you know that I just learned this they
say a couple bad apples but the next
part of that is a couple bad apples
ruins the barrel
right so it's like I have to be careful
with those thoughts and those feelings
because they can ruin everything
so what I would say is when when I take
the action to get out of self
when I become in service to others when
I do some reading when I listen to a
great podcast like this about people who
are Seekers who are trying to better
themselves if you take the action
something will change if you sit and you
try to wrestle it in my experience it'll
it'll never work
the question left for you
who is the one person in your life that
deserves the greatest thanks
and if you were to give them the thanks
today what would you say
well I
I I almost don't want to because it it
almost like because she loves she loves
her flowers but yeah I gotta give it to
my mom it all starts and ends with my
mom and we have a deeply imperfect
relationship because we're two deeply
imperfect people but at its core she did
more than I could have ever imagined and
especially being a father and seeing
what how challenging it can be with all
the help in the world and she did it all
by herself and I just give her all the
credit in the world so much of why I'm
here today is because of her so thanks
Mom I hope you don't watch this but
thank you I love you Josh thank you so
much it's been a an honor to meet you
and learn about your story and um I'm a
big following out of your YouTube
channel so please do post a lot more
because it's enjoyable to watch you
bring an important energy to the world
and your book is one of the most
vulnerable revealing but wisdom-laced
books I've had the privilege of of
reading in my research for a podcast
wait I recommend everybody to go grab a
copy I love the title happy people are
annoying
um it's a truly important book Thank you
Josh
as you might know the show's now
sponsored by Airbnb absolutely love
Airbnb always have always been a you
know saved my life on so many occasions
and my team when we first got in touch
with Airbnb were talking about how most
people don't realize that their place
where they currently live could become
an Airbnb and I guess the second
question there is how much could your
place be worth and it turns out you
could be sitting on an Airbnb gold mine
without even knowing it some people
Airbnb their entire homes when they're
away that's what I did in New York
whenever I left New York my place was on
Airbnb and people rented it out
sometimes for a day sometimes for two
days sometimes for a week and it's a
great way to cover some of the bills
while you're away so whether you're
looking to go on holiday or you just
want some extra cash for bills or you
want to buy something nice for a
valentine that you love whatever it
might be head over to airbnb.co.uk host
and you can find out how much your
current property where you live can earn
while you're not there I suspect it
might blow your mind because it
certainly blew mine
[Music]
uh